you know as a latin person you know
minorities black people have to do it as
well we have to immerse ourselves in
white culture and learn about white
culture and and it's all we were taught
in school and in movies and so we learn
but it's knit but it's not reciprocal
you know it's not a reciprocal thing
that happens that white culture wants to
learn about Latin culture or black
culture but there are a few they heard
for you Jane Elliott being one of the
great ones I think I mean in tackling it
in my industry it's like Hollywood so
Oscars so white that which was the
symptom of a disease which is Hollywood
is not making movies or being conscious
about including Latin and black people
in their movies when we're almost almost
50% of the population so it's a it's a
it's a very unbalanced representation of
reality and you know causes great harm
especially for youth who need to see
themselves in movies I think it's about
the the work needs to be done is not so
much understanding people of different
ethnic backgrounds as much as as giving
them the job sets that's really it
because we're all really the same we're
you know we're just slightly different
you know flavors and slightly different
colors but I think it's all about giving
those jobs and people rise up to the
occasion I mean that that's that's all
you got to do and what's interesting
because I just did my show I'm doing in
Berkeley and they brought this group of
high school kids and some of them were
Latin and they were just flabbergasted
the kids seeing a Latin person
performing on stage had never been to
the theater never seen a land person
onstage and it just changed their whole
entire perspective they all of a sudden
felt like they could do it you know and
it was a beautiful thing and just just
by organizations opening up and and
giving the opportunities that's how
these things happen it's kind of like
Viola Davis said three
she won that Emmy was because somebody
finally gave her the role that she
needed to win because she's always had
the same talent and she's always been
around but finally somebody wrote the
right role that was ample enough for a
person of color to win an Emmy I mean
there's a lot of issues or aspects of
myself because you know I'm also from a
lower-class socio-economic group and
that has a lot to do with differences
too you know I mean the fact is that
Latin and black people are mostly in the
in the lower socioeconomic groups so you
have that cultural gap it's an economic
gap culturally I mean I I guess I you so
the socio-economic group in America
becomes also your your ethnic and
cultural group and so yeah when I'm when
in certain groups you you want to
they're mostly predominately white you
want to appear predominantly white so
you use try to used a lingo and try to
use their their terminology and in the
way they speak you know like I'm talking
to you a little bit more right now I'm
talking to you with my whiter side of
myself more and they went out with my
friends from high school and we're all
like Latin in from a lower socioeconomic
group you know we'll well you know what
we'll we'll go back to the lingo that we
used you know like a little more Street
a lot more you you banach a lot more
Latin words you know because we know we
understand each other and and it did
this short hands and and that and that's
what we do you know I mean luckily I you
know when I was trying to be an actor
yet you know it was really difficult
because they weren't really when I
started out they weren't really casting
Latin people so and I had worked real
hard to cover you know to pass is what I
would say more pass as opposed to cover
but I'm sure that that goes on to you
know I had to try to clean my speech
you know so that it didn't have such a
street accent and but it wasn't didn't
matter because I I was still recognized
visually as a Latin person so even if I
changed the way I sounded or the way I
behaved it didn't matter because I was
gonna get cast in those roles anyway
because identify as a Latin person so
then I gave up and I was like you know
what forget it I'm not gonna try to fit
in I'm going to stay the way I am and
I'm gonna write for for my culture so I
started to write for people like myself
who grew up the way I grew up and and so
people of my socio-economic group and
and black people and Latin people in
some white people that I grew up in my
socio-economic group identify with me
and and that's the people I was talking
to I've been an outsider you know and
and continue to be an outsider but and
then in that being an outsider always
gives you a great artistic point of view
because you can see things and comment
on things and then trying to be white
made me an outsider in the hood because
I'm no longer as hoodie as I used to be
so I can hear that I sound very
different so that makes me an outsider
even in my own community so then I can
watch them too you know and you can
become a great observer and the
outspokenness just came out of I'm not
sure what that came out of a mostly a
necessity a need to to hear articulated
my experience that I wasn't hearing
articulated anywhere so I think I became
sort of a spokesperson just by by there
by wanting somebody to be fill in that
space for me and nobody was filling it
for me so I needed to I wanted to hear
and see somebody explain what it's like
to be a person like myself it's going
through the things that I'm going
through we've known for decades that
black people and Latin people have been
accosted
harshly by police and nobody believed it
nobody believed it they just you know
thought we were crying wolf and now
because of technology and cameras
everywhere you see what's going on you
you're it can't be hidden anymore oh I I
don't think America's as divided as it
was in my childhood I think it's much
more unified and much more open and much
more inclusive and consciously trying to
be inclusive I mean there are some
forces Trump supporters being one that
uh that feel that xenophobic and and
wanting to you know marginalize people
and separate but I think the rest of the
country is much more progressive and and
things are changing and people do care a
lot more and I think America is one of
the more progressive still the greatest
country in the world that way you know I
mean it's a place where I mean our
president is black are we're gonna have
a woman president next I mean we had two
latin candidates even though they were
on the wrong side
we had a Jewish candidate as well I mean
it's it's an incredible electoral cycle
really exciting and they're really
progressive so I think things aren't way
different and the beautiful thing is
that land people are going to decide who
the next president is and we count them
we're important and to me that's yeah
and that's that's part of the new
America